hi I'm Stan Stan the water man here to
bring water to the city of Los Santos
all these great good people here need my
water I'm here to give Stan the water
man has a purpose in life and that
purpose is to bring water to the great
people of this city as the Sun sets so
does the thirst rise time to be off
let's see if Stan's wise enough to have
locked his bike don't know if that's
lock or unlock oh it's a good day for
Stan looks like Stan's waking up on the
right side of the bed today I looked
like a bit of a nerd on this I'm not
gonna lie but I think that's what
everybody feels when they first have new
clothes it's like a new haircut not that
I'd ever get one but uh maybe this time
maybe today I'm gonna impress some more
ladies okay so where should I go what
should i do well I did a lot of delivery
work I think when I was asleep probably
but uh I remember distinctly doing a lot
of delivery work I don't think I need to
do any more for today I have a good bit
of dosh in the bank so maybe I could see
if someone out there is uh ready to
mingle around stop Stan
oh hi hey how's it going Jimmy are you
uh are you free am I free yeah we live
in America Jimmy all right that's me
Stan we live in America I'm always free
all right well I always love it when you
refer to yourself in the third person
but listen uh I find myself in a much
better position than I was before but
the Sun is setting so I'm thinking that
maybe it's an opportunity for us to make
some more cheddar or Jimmy doesn't know
what you're talking about
what do you mean cheddar it's time to
cut the Gouda act about farting no no
why would anyone call you on the phone
and say it's time to fart no I'm talking
it's tiny
what I mean but do I seem like a weird
person friendly J do I seem like a weird
person to you
yes all right that's fair enough but
it's time to shave the mozzarella the
Sun is setting wink wink okay what what
are you talking about cheese for I have
I don't deal I have some lockpicks and
I'm thinking that it might be time for
friendly nice stand to make a little
extra parmesan on the side okay what you
want to break into a Italian restaurant
I don't understand well you're half
right I but I'm talking about let me
make sure no one's around let me let me
hide real quick usually I'll just I
think I'm pretty stealthy here I'm
talking about using these lock picks
when the Sun sets on this fair city
to steal from the rich and give to the
US well I mean I was trying to be subtle
about it I don't I'm you whatever you're
are you in sure you're just looking for
making money right yeah well I'm in debt
i I owe 15,000 to Eugene his cab fares
are a little bit exorbitant and then I
owe $25,000 to someone by the name of
Murph
for acting lessons by the way I'm an
actor i I've been in two professional
projects so far well I mean the first
one I was I was more of a it was more of
a like a sensual lover's embrace style
film project but the next one I was
playing a crazed hobo who ran at a man I
think he was a lawyer screaming oh I'm
crazy I'm not robbing you but I'll cut
your face off if you don't get in the
trunk and then he got in the trunk and
then Ana fell off the vine would sign
and then I had to carry her all the way
to the hospital from the very tip-top of
the mountain it was a wild day yesterday
and I'm hoping that we can get down to
some excitement today experimental short
film no no it was it was a movie and a
commercial that's all you need to know
about it okay I mean I might have
another business venture for you if
you're interested he's a guy in Pulido
he's in the pharmacist pharmaceutical
yes and deliveries but you know how to
do good at deliveries I I I'm something
about professionally Stan the delivery
man is my own attacker right all right
well I'll introduce you to him where are
you I can pick you like I'm right
outside the job centre at the moment
uh-oh I'm stealthily hidden in the bush
I don't think anybody can see me at this
point but uh I'm uh I'm ready and
waiting I'm away okay all right thank
you thank you Jim Jimmy Jim a--they
friendly who's coming friendly
alright friendly so Jimmy's on the way I
Oh what are you doing is that you're
wearing uh well yes I'm shocked you
could spot me from my hiding place but
uh I uh misplaced my fanny pack and I
thought it was a good time to get a an
overhaul of my outfit and you see my my
Camelback here so I always stay hydrated
whenever I need hydration which is
pretty much always anyway how you been
good you know these train rides have
been getting longer and longer so I've
been out of town for a little bit but
good making money I got a new job at the
the winery for the daytime Oh the winery
that's pretty cool
I've never been up there I didn't even
know there was a winery up north
northwest dish pretty cool local area I
could put in a good word for you it's
going to next time the boss is in town
well maybe I mean what kind of work is
it ah you know it's some delivery work
you deliver grapes and and wine and yeah
you collect grapes from the vineyard
that's in that's my specialty
that's what I do exactly I do that well
I mean it's not water it's it's wine
which is not exactly a hydrator it's
okay it's all derivative of the same
product you know the only thing I love
more than delivering is real live dogs
dogs that are alive and cute and
adorable you can pet them right there
that's the only thing I love more yeah
no you seem a little sick there yeah
sorry yeah no I'm sweating a little yeah
I can see that you're pouring some water
to replace that hydration but anyway
I love dogs the cuteness of their voices
and their barks and their breath on your
with your face oh me too sometimes I
just want to cry as well so anyway you
still selling crack no no I mean why
your dream you loved it I I wouldn't
call it a dream it's uh it's it's a
living I guess oh really I'll be honest
I have a lot of crack really it's just
one gram of crack that I've been trying
to sell for awhile I haven't been really
successful but I think I might just keep
it for my own activities okay I still
consider you the friendliest crack
dealer in awe of will Santos but uh if
you want to keep it that's fine it might
be because you're so nice that you try
to stop everyone that tries to buy it
from you and try to lead them down the
path of righteousness and somehow I
found myself spiraling down a path of
darkness instead but not either way it's
all good it's fine here I'll introduce
you to this pharmaceutical job and
that'll that'll put you on a better path
I think so I you know I I was doing the
delivery work like earlier today and I
just felt it felt good to be on the
right side of the law it felt good to be
honest to be drying it I just felt alive
you know I'm really gonna win the
respect back of my son with with like
this turn about of my life it's exactly
exactly
this uh-oh I should I should probably
mention that maybe do the job we're
going to huh isn't entirely a great
topic to talk about government officials
Rai Rai Rai so at the DMV I should
mention this people in general know you
should keep this off of your
any sort of applications asking for your
occupation
so we're likes more besides spies no
more like drug delivery men we we
deliver goods oxycotin what yeah
oxycodone it whichever one that is oh
well those are legal oh okay for a
second I thought we were gonna do
something illegal oxycodone is perfectly
legal it's not this oxy whichever oxy it
is I don't know I'm bad with science so
what you're telling a good friend
friendly Jimmy he said I just spent the
last five minutes telling you about how
my life was turning around I was
enjoying being on the right side of
justice and then you the first thing
that I say to you when I get back into
the city and you're finally here is that
we're driving up to deliver illegal
oxycontin to some strange individual
there's actually multiple strange
individuals but yes uh-huh well I would
be livid right now but I just got a text
from someone asking me on a date I'm
Stan you I mean I did that halfway down
the road this is not because of it oh my
god finally finally on a real date hey
thought about a date or whatever with
you greasy water boy if you're like
bored or whatever xoxox Brenda the
receptionist oh my what yeah hello
just an let me no no let me let me there
there might be a problem here let me
reason with them they might just need
some water
hello hello hey you're gonna be excited
about this one I just got a date from a
beautiful girl by the name of Brenda oh
isn't that great news what who you're
not saying anything
oh are you stunned with disbelief Oh do
you just think oh oh I see you're saying
that someone like me wouldn't be able to
get it to know you're scoffing at me oh
you son of a [ __ ] awesome
that's what you get oh hey that's what
you get Stan yes this this guy's dead
look Jimmy people die it happens and he
can't be dead I just know there's a dead
man in the street and that that guy was
just oh that wasn't me this guy's dead
I think that guy killed this guy yeah
I'm like Batman except oh now he is
definitely dead yep yeah sorry lady she
is okay we gotta get out of here how we
got to talk to you just in there oh okay
all right you need do you have 750
dollars not on my person but is there a
bank in this city
there's a bank right there oh it's a
down payment he supplies us with a
delivery vehicle uh-huh I see let's just
check out the bank real quick I'm gonna
park my car right now
oh the bank of course it's where we had
our first a friendship event with that
robbery
I guess Oh bonding moment yeah of course
oh that was terminals those good times
they weren't criminals they were just
bird monkey and clown burped barren
clown I apologize all right well this is
the most money I've ever carried on me
as one time I probably shouldn't say
that loud enough money well I mean I've
got some money I've got I've got over
10,000 in the bank you you may also want
to start storing some of that cash under
maybe your mattress or something just in
case you get heavily in debt with the
bank why well I I would never be heavily
in debt with anybody I always tried to
pay my debts you never know you know
sometimes you get arrested and sometimes
they bill you direct with your eye I
don't think I'd ever be arrested for
anything well I mean I know I'm gonna
I'm I'm as clean as the water I so
that's like 10% legs so well I mean it's
impossible to decontaminate that levels
of lead that it like in this city and
and people have built up a tolerance
anyway so the city is actually well
suited for it anyway this is the place
if you want to head on in he's at the
you can talk about right Oh Stan what
are you doing I what did you did you see
you walked up to the door and then you
started running and screaming to the
middle of the street there's been ghost
problems in this city as of late and I
think I had another experience ah no no
no you're hallucinating the air and
nothing else will happen Oh everything's
fine is it apparently are you inside
I hear you yes are you coming in or
should I just talk to this gentleman
here I mean you can just talk to him I
don't really need go in Oh awesome okay
all right thank you sir I just take the
keys and it sits outside okay all right
thank you all right told you about that
the car yeah you said it was somewhere
outside he didn't give me specific
directions buddy who's vaguely over in
that direction right I think that's it
that's it over there okay well we'll see
should I should I Drive them oh you
should drive
for sure oh good I've been getting a lot
of driving experience with the delivery
truck so any other vehicle should be a
cakewalk at that point yeah you try
getting a delivery truck at 80 miles an
hour down the down the city streets to
get a delivery on time this will be no
problem marked where you need to go
unfortunately I'm not seeing it looks
like maybe a little cocaine got it all
right let's uh let's get e on e should I
obey speed limits should I Drive safely
or do you want to get this delivery done
quick you drive do you want to drive in
any case we're delivering illegal goods
so it's probably best we don't get
caught okay yeah are there are there
like speed radars along the highway or
things of that nature the cop is there
any way to know if a cop is sir
if you see a cop
right okay success simple yeah so you
know things don't always have to be
complicated and fancy and newfangled you
know Rui Rui Rui right and if say we do
hold over what do we like what do we do
I mean if I were you I would drive away
really fast because this isn't our car
technically so they can't really run the
plates and lead it back to you so if we
get away we're fine okay so uh what's
the cruise control [ __ ] this
cuz I'm feeling good I'm feeling the
sudden urge to drive very safely no I
think it's X it is but it's not working
oh it limits the top speed I see I see I
see I still have to hold the accelerator
down it's a funky cruise control but
that's a weird it's one of those Russian
cruise control yeah yeah and and also
what's where where's the seat belt on
this thing where where's uh where's the
seat it's tier left you see you just
stretch that B muscle on your right arm
and you can reach over and grab that ah
my my B muscle I had that removed as a
childhood I think are they replaced it
with a different muscle oh so I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna I'll be fine
without it feels restrictive on my
shoulders you know I got my walk my
camel belly I don't have a B muscle I
have one I just know my muscles got
changed around as a kid I got an a
horrible industrial accident I got
passed through a through a through a
pressure which separates wheat from the
chaff its I and and my whole body got
discombobulated and they stitched me
back together mostly okay but it just so
happens that I I some muscles got some
other places you know what for you I'm
gonna look at my biology textbook I have
from high school in my back pocket I
always come on me see if I can maybe
find what the B muscle normally does in
the Baja uh-huh that's a good that's
that's a good idea if you have a muscle
that doesn t sort of pointing I think
that's it oh you all
you got it you know my body better than
I do which just means it was such good
friends friends do you want to know my
body more nope I mean I'm friendly I'm
just not that that kind of friendly I
mean you could be could be if this were
a play they'd call that character
development but I guess you just know
we're rough road I guess you just don't
wanna I guess you just you don't want to
take risks I got one a rumors spreading
on that may already be spreading around
certain areas to be reciprocated and
turn it into a thing well that's all I'm
gonna say are you talking about your
your history with prostitution let's
just say maybe at my new job everybody
thinks I'm gay ah well that's that's
interesting
oh is it this this is this person I mean
if they're standing there it might be
them
hello just give it to them all right
well there there there you go have a
good day stay in the water man here to
hurt it Thanks
all right oh wow
friendly he gave me money he gave me
three Hyundai exactly that's what this
is all about now um it doesn't happen
often but sometimes these guys they get
an idea that they don't owe you anything
and they run away sometimes it's best to
use force ah ha I see you happen to pick
up that uh that baseball bat you were
talking about I have a knife that I used
to abduct the the lawyer Murphy just
yesterday that works I mean it's a stunt
knife but it look at it it looks really
scary ya know if they if they try to run
away after taking the drugs just dog
won't stab them alright okay sounds good
um and do we just head back and pick up
another bag dog romaine lettuce wink
wink wink we're just good for a nap oh
we just drive around until you'll see it
on your little minion GPS at the bottom
left of your dash by see it actually I
already another little thing yeah
got it got it and I'm assuming that
we're gonna split everything 50/50 here
correct what's in this run is all yours
mostly because I didn't pay a cent to
get here so I'm gonna help but but
you're keeping me company you're you're
you're obviously you're obviously making
this worth the ride and it was your idea
finder's fee and all that it's best if
you just don't pay me for this just in
case you are sloppy because it is your
first time and we get caught
oh um I wasn't a part of it all right
okay I will keep that to myself
so anyway this a Brenda situation I
haven't even texted her back oh well I
mean what should I oh my god what are
you doing what what I'm not texting her
now why could I want me to park right
now pull over we'll hang on what no we
got to get to the other delivery I can
tell I've texted and driven all the time
oh is this one of those self-driving
cars yeah it probably is let's see and
I'm gonna pull out the phone here all
right not one of the self-driving cars
all right well I did I wasn't ready to
text anyway what do you mean what should
I which I say am i under Sun let's make
this delivery we'll worry about what the
text Brenda Oh Oh Brenda she had eyes
like sunrise this this delightful bun of
a hair her jacket was the color of
turquoise and and and and Jade as it
sprinkled off of the the the the Chinese
river it was beautiful I I can't even
fathom to describe another human being
that could possibly be as beautiful as
Brenda wasn't she she chastised me in
such a way that made me feel alive
inside my loins do you know what I mean
I have a line for you you should text
her back and say Brenda more like benda
you over I I don't I don't think that's
I okay don't work are you sure I think
about all the lines I've given you
uh-huh
if you I mean 100% of the time
you know your your your right you you
are right hang on I have to I have to
stop right now hang on I have to fight I
trust you Jimmy you've never led me
astray before I follow your advice to
the ends of the earth one second just
gotta add her to my phonebook because I
know this is gonna lead to a long and
lengthy conversation yeah I mean this
could be the future mother of my other
children it could be if you ever do have
sex cuz that didn't happen with your
last wipes it did not but I mean this
could be this could be like this could
be big all right I'm a I'm a no texture
should I should I like add a winky face
emoji or something like that or maybe
like a band oh my god they go so fast
yes all right perfect okay perfect okay
got it got it perfect all right I sent
it okay I sent it all right wait I
didn't even ask her uh where where where
she wanted to go I didn't ask her I did
I didn't I didn't even ask about the
date later
you gotta get the response you got a
gauging oh I see I see I see you're
right you you're right when you are
right you are right you ever heard of a
probing question this approving question
or a statement I guess uh-huh uh-huh
okay all right good probing for the
response to see if she's super envy you
uh-huh okay all right okay then you bend
out her over this and then I do I do the
thing where I I take my my um I put my I
put I put I put both of my ball I I put
I I reach in I reach inside with my with
my hand I think and I I like I make a
scooping motion I I think I I think I've
seen it whoa okay let's focus on driving
instead of whatever the [ __ ] you're
talking about
well I mean I'm talking about sex I can
focus on driving and talk about sex all
I want you think that sex what I mean I
mean it can be but it's not
I read additional yeah I read in the
books it says you need to you need to
spread the this the reading well I mean
mostly medical books
something about inserting a
medical device and making a spreading
motion and inspecting the cervix anyway
here we are hello
tell this guy about it alright what do
you think of sex what is what does sex
mean to you well how do you sex would
you would you say that you sex good
would you say alright anyway all right
thank you for nothing yeah sort of a
just all business type of guy okay all
right I'm gonna be honest you were
describing a pap smear what a pap smear
it's kind of a checkup that ladies get
what is spreading and inspecting
whatsapp app you need to I don't know
what porn or something well I mean I
won't you be a good instruction oh yeah
I'm not allowed not old enough what do
you mean not old enough I thought you
had to be of retirement age before you
could watch porn you know when you were
passed beyond the ability where you
would be having sex normally then you
turn over to porn as a substitute told
you that no one told me about it I've
read about it people I mean there are
forums where people talk about her
things are illegal and not illegal or if
you not read them if you go to any site
that you may think may be some sort of a
porn site I just want you don't even
have to click on any videos you don't
have to click on anything just want you
to go the first page of that and just
read what it's not retirement age okay
well I mean I guess since I am dipping
my toes into the the other side of the
law I suppose breaking another rule like
that but definitely check it out like an
application product process in like 39
yeah I'm 39 one of it Jesus Christ what
what how could you be 39 you have never
looked at porn in your life I mean
because I wasn't allowed to because it's
illegal and before I came to this city I
didn't do anything illegal never not
even once
you never jaywalked never never I don't
know just not done your taxes one year
never always early in fact I prepay if
you prepay quarterly you estimate your
future earnings which mine are always
very very very regular with my water
delivery schedule as it is or at least
it was before I came to this city and he
prepaid you make
Smithson you you make sure that Uncle
Sam gets his due wave ahead of schedule
okay all right well anyway I guess I'll
what what uh what porn website would you
suggest
pornhub or something I don't know
whatever you could just just you have
fun search the internet maybe I could
ask Brenda probably just ask her what
her favorite friend oh that is perfect
that was a great conversation ask her
you don't
next time she text you back you ask her
what her favorite porn site is okay well
I'm actually surprised she hasn't texted
me back maybe I should just preemptively
get ahead of it and that way I could
show her that I'm black I'm savvy to the
to the sex to the sexing I'm I'm top
quality and sexing shows you're in that
industry that's why you're curious about
right right okay all right hang on I
gotta make it I gotta make this text
this is too important yeah yeah rot no
she didn't she must be she must be
really impressed
you must be yeah yeah just send out the
porn question and that'll that'll
probably get her looking at that any any
emojis I should attach on this probably
like the tongue out emoji that's it's
the tongue out winky face and then the
the hand that's a fist and then the the
what is it the eggplant emoji and then
the the water like the what is
sprinkling water emoji and then the
tongue emoji just the what the one with
just the tongue you do that like three
times okay so I said hey so what type of
porn do you watch if you had to pick
from your top 10 or 20 favorite
pornographic websites that you like to
peruse I'd like to compare our mutual
interests and followed by the emojis
that's what I would have written but
okay go ahead alright you got it and
sent perfect this is gonna be great
thank you no time yeah I know I know
unless she's too enamored with me and I
only have you to thank Jimmy I really
honestly truly I'm so thankful for know
for this what you doing anything for a
friend like you I just appreciate you so
much for helping me to understand how to
navigate these free situation because I
would be lost
I'd be texting things like like what do
you like to do in your spare time
parodies what food do you out boring
things like I would not know where to go
yeah like who the [ __ ] cares about
interests right yeah I mean I do but you
know knowing more about the person like
you don't really need to know well I do
but I mean I would like to do you not
have to know just gotta [ __ ] oh oh
well I mean yeah and then that's it if
it's [ __ ] coming in but I move on to the
next one
no but what about falling in love and in
marriage and children and and oh no no
that's that's all just like a trap no no
one fall into that but no but not that
old that'll lock you in for life and you
don't want to be flying solo Hawaiian
solo like Han Solo in the Millennium
Falcon in that cool but he had Chewbacca
with him the entire time he was never
really solo and I'm your Chewie oh okay
that's that's not as reassuring as I
thought no actually that's all right
maybe I'll get used to it just keep
doing it
no still bad okay all right okay
not good okay well I mean also didn't
Han Solo get married to Leia and then
you know I had a kid I mean he turned
out to be a real shitty kid apparently
but uh you know I've only seen a new
hope so I don't know what you're talking
about
I mean why would Han Solo ever get
married he's not a relationship type of
guy right you know you might be like I
just I got a text back story I got a I
have to pull over I have to pull over
I'm so excited yes yes yes do you think
do you think she's gonna propose in it
do you think this text is don't bring no
okay all right I gotta do something Oh
she said Oh Stan who is writing your
text for you I think she's onto you
Oh what do I do say nobody shoddy and
then it smelled SSH a wty just FYI
no one shoddy just me your home boy Stan
the man with the plans to bone you in
the zone the bone zone okay all right
you're gonna need to repeat that slowly
I will type it as you say it right no no
one shoddy just me Stan the man with the
plan to take you to the bone zone yo and
then you do the tongue out of mode D and
then the fist emoji and then the
eggplant emoji and then those sprinkling
water emoji and then the tongue emoji
three times okay I think I got it and
maybe you can throw like one of those
100 emojis to those work too you can
just kind of sprinkle those okay I think
I got it oh no I've been abducted by
aliens I hear you I see you what is
going on here in the tremors in my ice
cream in darkness I have to send this
man just said to send a message this
happened here I can't see anything
find out what's going on you can't see
okay I can't see
oh no no not again not again sucked in
your phone oh you focused oh no I think
I think my people are calling me are you
okay you're hallucinating again no God
[ __ ] this happened with the water nation
is this crap it's just pure darkness I
feel like I have to slip into a deep
sleep and hopefully maybe I'll I'll wake
up and you know and oh you flex your f8
muscle and you see feel a crash muscle
uh-huh work for sure I think I can feel
it and if you do that it might make the
train a little faster in the town I
think so
look you tell Brenda you send out a
tweet you tell Brenda okay you tell
Brett stand left out it is coming back
yeah you tell Brenda I'll be held
Brendon I'll be back I'll see you when I
see it
Stan I'm so mad God God we were on such
a good roll there [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yeah Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy is that
you yeah it's it's it's me oh good I I
am good I'm back I I closed my eyes
I clicked my heels three times and I
wish real hard and I'm back in Pulido
well it looked like you got out of the
car and ran as fast as you could at
different directions so I'm guessing you
ran all the way to Pulido i-s I did I
must have I must have really conked out
there yeah that is funny these fumes
will get you if you're new to the city
really will start getting used to it and
it'll it might get better you know yeah
I think this said you're back in Polly
oh yeah I'm back in Pulido I figured
that you we were on the way to Polito so
it might be beneficial for me
right here and and maybe I can maybe I
can pick you up oh wait oh hello oh hi
yeah I wasn't sure if you'd be able to
use the car
I may have finagled away to use the car
oh you're so crafty by chance on your
GPS does it still show the ability to
make the delivery you have to absolutely
not
we'll probably have to go again but hey
what's a couple hundred dollars between
friends
but yeah what's what's another I mean
I've got the cash
I've I've got a lot of dosh I mean hey
if you want to do it again
well I'll make it down payment and
thanks right there well uh we'll just
we'll call it and we'll call it even and
we'll keep going even steven all right
oh oh a van Stan what anyway I got a
text Brenda if you want to pull money go
for it I'll I'll be here and I'll wait
in the car
all right Stan let's see if you remember
this all right whoa or it's all the wise
words no one is shoddy it's just your
boy stand the man with the plan
to take you to the bone zone
yo finger gun emoji winky face smile
alright get the job started and then
I'll just split the cash with yet after
all right sound sound sorry it sounds
good
Charlie speaking with my inside voice
yeah there's a little bit of an echo
around here sometimes weird winds and
all that anyway
alright this seems good I think this is
gonna work no one is shoddy it's just
your boy stand the man with the plan to
take you to the bone zone yo finger gun
emoji smile and plan water 100 should be
good alright send it off and copulations
will commence come come former
fornication we shall copulate okay
alright
I I mean I I hope I don't have to
abandon Jimmy deny to faith if the night
turns out to be more more wet and wild
it usually is with my water business but
normally you never know I won't have
many other chances to be as involved
with with someone else
Oh Oh Jimmy are you yeah alright nice
car
I'm sure we can just leave that one
there they'll probably find us alright
well I sent the message and I actually
just already got another message hate me
got my okay alright I'll give you the
juicy details hang on she said Wow Stan
you've really changed I thought you were
different said to see how you're just
like all the other guys in this town
wait no wait it's no no it's a bait no
it's a bait how is this afraid it's very
clearly not a baby she is trying to get
you to respond in an alpha manner we
right but I thought I was no alpha no
alpha would take that kind of [ __ ]
so you gotta say hey [ __ ] listen the
[ __ ] up
oh my god I'm Who I am from day one and
you're gonna respect that are you sure
I'm 100% sure but I but I mean what have
I ever led you astray well I mean it
feels like right now maybe I might have
misstep I mean I was
crafting that text from memory from what
you said before so maybe maybe you're
right maybe I didn't remember something
right I should have asked you before I
sent it I should have okay this might
recorrect the course okay okay all right
so read it out loud I'll type it word
for word and I will not mess up at all
say listen here [ __ ] rage face emoji I
do not take this kind of [ __ ] rage face
emoji you respect me for who I am who I
have been from day one rage face emoji
you hear that 100 emoji 100 emoji 100
religion okay I feel like this is a
little little aggressive more aggressive
than I would I would usually do is a
little aggressive but that's just called
being alpha which you want to be alpha
okay the beta before being all finally
caring about emotions and tears and you
know dreams and all that do you think
that's why Denise left me because I was
a beta yeah Stan honestly yes well
alright man up all right you're right
you're right you're right I do need not
give in to that testosterone I do I feel
or me I do way away from soy milk okay
all right don't drink soy milk at all
it's only water and I guess I could eat
a few more meats I'm sending it here we
go three steak a day that's the way to
go one I sent it I said I feel it I feel
alpha I feel I feel good exactly you
need to start - oh my god taking control
of your life must have been the
testosterone he must have I must have
had a weight shift and then threw you
off exactly that was it and not at all
my faulty driving oh I'm there it is
Stan I'm getting ready ho all right hang
on I gotta answer this hello Stan why
are you texting like that I mean I I am
I feel like I'm why I just I am
believing in I'm I'm not being a beta
I'm I'm being an alpha alpha I'm being
an out I'm an alpha I'm beyond a second
to meet me
well I mean I'm in the middle of um I'm
I'm with a friend and I we're in the
middle of some perfectly perfectly legal
activities and we're I wouldn't meet you
now but I I got a I have to dab on that
haters and flex on the plebs and I have
to I gotta get that good cush Stan yes
can you call me when you're done with
that and so I can meet you face-to-face
Hospital okay all right will do yes my
friend might need it actually I think he
just fell out of the car I'll be right
back goodbye you are you all right I'm
okay are you fine are you sure yeah was
it my Alfa Ennis did it knock you out of
the car yeah it yes it was forceful ooh
I must be really intimidating anyway
that was Brenda
um I she was she really wants to meet me
face to face now which i think is a good
thing oh my god I told you Stan yeah she
wants me to come over the hospital right
now she said right now so she can see me
face to face
yes I mean right now do we have time I
mean I need to ditch this car I don't
know if it's technically stolen or not
well I mean yes we'll go right now oh
thank you thank you Jimmy I I mean
couldn't have done this without you you
are truly a great friend a great
inspiration and good to me it's what I
do
well I'm nervous I've got butterflies
like I don't even know what I'm gonna
say when I get over there I mean I did
that phone call by myself I but I
exactly how do I look i yo what is what
is what is good what's how are you and
were you texting me all that stuff I'm
doing
were you the one where you called me a
[ __ ] well I mean I I just um I needed
to uh my eye
I needed to be alpha I needed to be
alpha I needed to assert my alpha nature
I'm very testosterone is colored you
need to be just be alpha I am I am alpha
I I am I am I am alpha uh-huh so do you
want to show me your alpha now that I'm
standing in front of you Stan I well I I
just yeah I know no go ahead go ahead
I'm mr. moon mr. moon I don't know what
you're calling me when you're right
there please wait a second she's right
there
you know why you're okay
hey [ __ ] do you want to go to the bones
oh no no wait wait restart that restart
that again start that time since all
over and start it again yeah we start
restart hey [ __ ] do you wanna just
let's just let's just calm things down
let's just okay it's a little bit of a
misunderstanding do absolutely anything
at all that was all okay honest listen I
want Stan alone stop trying to make him
alpha I just let him do it say hey wait
a minute come with me come with me am i
part of this conversation to stand
outside okay all right okay all right so
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
you really GU for
this time how could you do this how
could you do this to yourself
[Music]
you're not alpha you're not even beta
your gamma your Omega
Oh your Omega beta gamma you're nothing
you're not alpha you're nuts special
you're not great you're not nothing you
are just the worst who is that
hello you want to be my friend okay
[Laughter]
hello we're gonna forget what happened
okay
oh okay listen just don't listen to what
this guy's telling you if he's trying to
say it be alpha just literally do the
opposite of what he's saying okay are
you are you hurt by the way I'm only
moderately it's like I'll live okay all
right oh my god oh my god
I've been busy Abdul okay let's get you
inside
okay great job that was all part of the
play wait what was it what that I get
hunched in the face my feelings and my
emotions got hurt
yeah and now she feels bad for you so
she's gonna lean back on you and take it
easy she's gonna treat you even better
than she did before because of that you
know that right
really you you think you ever heard the
good cop bad cop well yeah well I mean
I'm seeing it you're the good cop well
I'm the bad cop I made you do those
things I'm the bad guy in this scenario
and you're the good guy oh and she's up
looking after the good guy
that's Jimmy you are you're just the
best friend a Stan could ever hope to
ask for thank you thank you
oh well what do I do now do I do I need
do I do I rush up to her like she's into
[ __ ] so I what just forget all the
alpha [ __ ] I said you are you're plenty
of enough she's a lesbian is saying
you're good all I could say is you're
good you're in the clear you don't need
to take my advice anymore for her at
least maybe maybe other chicks if you
want to you know double dip hold on hold
on hold on I'm busy soon okay all right
well the skirt skirt oh well I was not
what was talking about her skirt names
elected night uh-huh I mean we should
just sounded like one of those one of
those rap ad-libs I don't know what you
what I don't know what you're talking up
no I've seen worse I just wanted to say
I just wanted to say I'm sorry for the
derogatory things that I said you are a
very lovely person and I'm happy to have
met you
also I got I got you these flowers
anyway you see I have to we have to go
we have deliveries that we have to make
but I'm good I think that went better
than I could have ever possibly hoped
that went swimmingly you beyond
swimmingly and the rain the water I'm
glad you've knocked the windshield out I
can feel it on my face the cleansing
spirit of the rain and definitely
something I did on purpose oh it's so
freeing it's beautiful
I could [ __ ] feel the the pain of my
my previous relationship washing away oh
well I mean I ran into her in the
hospital one time and I said her I said
her
pun was nice and her eyes were like
sunrise but I might have screamed that
at her I'm not sure I can't require
remember but yeah we uh we met at the
huh in that very Hospital I can tell you
guys might be getting a little bit
closer so I should probably warn you I
still your friend still very friendly
uh-huh but if you talk about any of our
other business I will have to cut your
balls off Bob yeah okay all right
duly noted a friend friendly
anyway so uh is this delivery that we've
got okay all right remember how we met
right yeah yeah I do I do remember what
we did together I mean we we drove to
the bank and then we peruse some houses
and then oh and then you you talk about
the guy in the yeah okay all right hey I
just got a text okay hang on what you I
got a text
let me just update me oh well maybe I'll
keep this one to myself Wow we're all
all up okay I'll update you yes she said
listen if you ever want to go out for
food or something let me know I wow
that's a real date that's a real real
real date that that is a real date I
I'll tell her I'm busy for now because I
have soiled myself multiple times and
there's urine soaking through every
fiber of my clothes at this point but um
I you know I mentioned maybe not taking
my advice for the texting but just this
one little piece leave out the soiling
of yourself are you sure you said to be
myself and I you have to sleep out that
I definitely be yourself just yourself -
the peeing your own pants like my
chlorine other people's cars
you know just yeah okay all right well
I'll leave it out but I can't promise
I'll stop doing it but uh okay I'll let
her I'll let her know
okay sounds good I'm a little busy at
the moment but
we'll let you know when I'm free in the
near future smile alright prime
condition alright sorry I used my inside
voice again ice I sent a nice text I
didn't mention anything about the yeren
perfect you want some water you thirsty
I've got I've got a bunch in this gamble
back alright well let me know I'm just
gonna slog down a few dozen bottles yeah
I seem to still have the oxy from the
previous deal or I felt someone like
possibly slipping something into my
backpack while I was at the hospital I'm
not a hundred percent sure but I have 25
bottles of oxy nice you could just take
it I guess let me just do it right now I
mean you're still in pain from the whole
getting punched in the face yeah I never
got that treated but honestly I don't
think I'll wash my face again after
after Brenda I mean should I I mean it's
not dangerous is it no all right well
okay down the hatch not low dosages just
sick what okay one or two one or two or
five okay real quick
oh that's that's
things feel a little weird
maybe I should probably
[Music]
oh my god
it's fine huh Jimmy Oh God oh yeah yo yo
ha hey Tripp you're right oh you okay
what's wrong
you need some oxy ah you heard I got I
got 24 more pills all right I'm all
right I'm all right just a few scratches
what just happened I don't know if I
took some oxy and you ran away like a
little baby so I thought you were
possessed nothing happened to my voice
it's always been the same as it always
been I mean that bat really took the
edge off that and that painkiller that
works I mean all deep in an echo Ian
what are you talking about he's
literally something like a demon Oh
Jimmy we have a delivery to make
come on now come on now come on it's
been a long night
yeah the smog the fog the smoke the
pollution of the fumes
all right anyway you sure you don't want
any of this I got me up so I'm good okay
all right well onwards and upwards
don't forget your what
don't forget your seatbelt Oh got it my
bed just want to make sure you're safe
what
I completely say I feel safe I feel 100%
woman you should safe while you're doing
this I'm just gonna go into my head for
a little bit maybe take some more oxy
but I'm fine whoa okay slept with my
eyes open huh whoa you need to maybe you
should stay away from drugs you don't
seem like you bought it doesn't seem
like your body really agrees with them
like at all well I mean many what I
don't think you can make that kind of
objective decision I feel like I'm
pretty spry feel better than ever we're
making money were
can friends I might be making lovers I
just I feel like I feel like if anything
breaking the rules is what's really
pulling my life together sure you don't
sound too sure but you know I again I
can only thank you for this and I can
only appreciate what you've done again I
can't say it enough you're completely
right it's on me of course
so is are these deliveries just gonna
keep going endlessly or until we run out
don't just kind of keep going if you
want to do something else it's like no
no and I'll give you your cut no no we
can we can keep going we got us deliver
we got to make some dosh we got a we got
to make some moolah we got to really
kind of really dig me deep you you
really wanna I do i I do wanna we could
start maybe delivering other other types
of drugs I mean you have that one crack
on you there's got to be someone that's
willing to pay out the middle one crack
I'll just tweet it out hang on
oh don't don't treat it don't point on
not tweet that no it's fine I don't mind
it's okay are you kidding you're saying
your friend has crack no don't say that
no I'm not saying my friend I'm saying
does friendly juf friendly Jay has crack
know people know me as that name well I
mean then they'll know who to contact
anyone just put my phone number in there
that I swear to god if you tweet that
out what just maybe make it a bit more
inconspicuous like oh I don't know I did
has a rock that he likes to throw let me
know if you want that rock to be thrown
it ah I like it and that way we'll get
more cheddar oh and my salad and I see
where you're going okay I tweeted it out
I think I did it right did you see it
let me read this tweet hold on uh-huh
Christ what's wrong what's wrong it'll
do it's really good right it's fine
it's great it's great it's great it's go
huh it's great we're gonna be doing I
think they're the people that know what
it's all about are really gonna
understand what we're talking about
I think the throw
in the catching euphemism that's really
gonna really gonna bring in the business
yeah nobody else was reading it say you
know well I mean I hope that everybody
reads it all right oh wow thank you
that's that's so generous I mean that's
it
you are such a good friend I am so
grateful to you oh I'm so grateful to do
you and for your generosity I appreciate
that
yes I guess I guess that's it right
unless you want to unless there are any
more deliveries on you're probably a
good idea
probably yeah yeah and he calls any tax
not yet all right well maybe I should
maybe I should be a little it looks a
little too inviting maybe that's it but
you want me to tweet again that's the
only tweet again I'll do it like a
clarification tweet it's a comma make
sure people know I figure we didn't mean
other things what are the things could
you possibly be talking about oh maybe
they'd literally think we're talking
about a rock nobody wants to buy a rock
oh I see I see
Oh golden okay all right Stan I really
panicked I thought I thought it was
gonna be locked forever I just get in my
panic a lot oh my god all right let me
let me craft up another one
alright how's that one did you did you
get that tweet oh is that good
Oh a customer would you look at that I'm
getting a car summer you it is alright
it's gonna be the bully it's gonna be
okay we can't sell crack on Twitter ah
well I mean why not
that was nice officer Oh what does it do
the police luckily you did not give out
my name
you just gave out a stupid old phone
number so we're good I think we're good
are you very sure I mean maybe maybe the
police was interested in the meantime I
I don't think he was he sounded very
angry well well I mean he doesn't even
know what we were selling I drove that
extremely subtly no no he started to
call off with are you selling crack on
Twitter
oh I said no my friend is and then he
said I am with the police department
because I was ah but that I beg can see
where that went wrong if I'd have been
on the phone I probably could have
navigated you your expertise may be
women but my expertise is negotiating
business deals they were interested they
were just playing hard to get they were
just playing hard to get no no they
wanted it maybe they want oxy maybe
convince him call him back see if they
want oxy oh you should you should maybe
make a tweet that you're selling that
oxy cuz you get sell that to people
yeah it's perfectly legal right okay
alright maybe you should make that sweet
all right will do and maybe put your
phone number not my phone no I'll put
yours
did you get my tweet yeah I saw it it's
really Ollie oxy in free it's way fun
doesn't that make it sound like it's
it's free oxy
well let me sounds like freon maybe we
can do a deal where it's like no no bit
well I mean I've read that drug deal
okay this is gonna be huh
what's wrong there's another cop what is
the same cop actually the same cuz I was
going great there's a long phone call we
got a sound we got a sale yeah
Oh for the crack yeah oh good I do okay
good that's that's perfect that's what
you wanted yes this is perfect huh this
is so great so first we got to go to my
apartment so I can grab the brach okay
all right okay then we're gonna meet the
guy behind the back alley of the
apartments perfect perfect perfect I'm
fine everything's fine except the
Cardinal will be right we're good we're
completely healthy
this is it this is it this is it I feel
good about this
see I told you life is coming around
when you make moves in the wrong
direction okay play it cool
all right howdy officer sorry I just I
had my earbuds in 201 1030 up here on
niether motor both those suspects say
they don't do the Audi anyway how you
doing I'm gonna turn off the engine I
think that's your probably the next
thing you'd ask me right I'm doing
fantastic what brings you gentlemen out
this way uh we're just gonna I'm gonna
swing by the bank grab some cash
yeah you want to send down two more
units just as the same people who were
so far I'm not sure I mean I've been
selling water around he might know me
from that of course we're fine why
wouldn't we be fine ups I think we ran a
red that's probably do you have a form
of registration to the vehicle and also
a form of identification in which I
could see please I sure reaching around
looking for things you keep your hands
where I can see him son well of course
wouldn't dream of it
all right here you go there's the
license to the registration okay you
know the news team you guys you guys are
part of a news team yeah I was I forgot
to clock out I okay nice I'm a delivery
man myself specialize in water
deliveries if you need water stand the
water man is your man okay I'll be back
with you momentarily sounds great sounds
good yeah you might want to send the
SWAT team why would they need a SWAT
team
I don't know yeah I think I must be must
be like a bank robbery around here or
something okay Stan we I'm probably fine
of course we're fine you seem to be I'm
not worried at all hey now you need some
oxy do you need to calm down
nope nope nope and I don't know where
you would even get oxy that's a weird
thing to say right now in this situation
where you might be on your shot to hear
something like that it's a weird joke
what
how's it going I like your eye response
you got to calm down I'm bad in social
situations the law enforcement is here
you can trust the law enforcement at all
times is right so you can't trust the
law enforcement to enforce the law and
you should not be nervous unless you've
broken a law and Jimmy you haven't
broken any laws today have you there's
no need for me to call and Swan and
bring them round this corner and a chart
with the m16 pointed at you right now is
this
absolutely that I just okay okay officer
I'm gonna be honest with you
I was I was speeding back there oh yeah
sure me I was I was I was I got the
artist I can't I can't just try to
weasel out of this oh I should have done
something about that officer I can
actually explain that one actually about
a hundred feet back there just before
you pull this over we are sideswiped as
we were crossing an intersection by a
huge huge truck smashed the windows in
that is that's completely factual then
you failed to report the crime to the
police is that what else you're saying
Oh Jimmy Jimmy you didn't call them I'm
gonna go see if that's a felony and I
need to take you to jail Jimmy stand
Jimmy what have you done innocent two
trucks sending the two trucks this is
definitely that and the more the merrier
I say for our safety
she said SWAT that the two trucks he was
holding is really nervous do you need
some regular thing
you're spoiling a lot I do need some
water I'm gonna drink some water some
water all right you made a drop in oxy
in this water and give it to you that
probably calm you right down nope okay
okay I occasionally stir the vehicle Oh
Thank You officer thank you so much
you're not even gonna the this you're
not oh okay thanks but this is your
warning Jimmy you follow the law that's
right I follow the lime so sorry officer
but you need to tell me about sir Jimmy
me I do not feel that that is their
place well you beatin on people where
you I see the vehicle just like this in
front of the PO
later away can I have reports of a man
matching your description in which was
beating people they said a man with blue
hair and his skinny neck was up there
beaten down well officer I was with him
almost the entire time I can vouch for
him except for a brief 5-minute window
where I I blacked out for a moment and
then I maybe in that time period but it
would be a very small time frame i but I
can't account for any jewelry today
perhaps no no jewelry not not today
necklace me I definitely bought it I
didn't take any any jewellery reason you
shoot me when I told you you could go
about two or three minutes ago you
making me know I think you're up don't
be honest I'm not used to such if I
Drive away right now is that okay with
you he said it was okay Jimmy why are
you so nervous
I think it's Oh what if I just kind of
started don't answer it hands-free is
not what I'm doing
we're just gonna get alright okay now
Jimmy you obey the law you've been a bit
naughty
Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy sorry I have anxiety
apparently you do I do
maybe if I take one and then breathe it
on you maybe you better laugh like an
effect here let me pop one real quick
might work I'm just gonna try we gotta
sell this crack oh yeah we don't even
have it alright we just got to hit the
apartments in you go
fine fine Oh God not this again
tell them well the scary demon [ __ ]
Jimmy huh Martin oh I took a noxian
every time I take an oxy that guy gets
really scared he runs away anyway welp
he was stressed out I wasn't no I
figured that if I took it and kind of
breathed on him it would help him not
stress out but he just seemed to be more
stressed out oh well I'm gonna go find
him and see what's up I'm staying the
water man by the way if you need water
I'm your man
Tom damn champion Dom Dominique man yo
Dom well pleasure to meet you dumb if I
had more time to talk I would but I've
got to get going
take care Oh bye-bye like oh hey buddy
I just got a pop in my apartment real
quick I'll be right there
go for it go for it I'll wait here I'm
just gonna die I'm gonna drop this
[ __ ] oxy off hardcore I gotta get it
off me I'm just gonna put it away
[ __ ] get ready get rid of it all
right okay righty-roo good buddy all set
and ready to go okay let's go see if
they're there I mean I don't see why not
I gotta see if I can call that guy back
all right all right well we did get
stopped there for a little bit
I don't know it's let him know that you
talked to the police beforehand and uh
everything's hunky-dory right hello oh
jeez uh-oh that old man is on his phone
hey whoa hey follow me okay all right
it's me follow me okay so uh did you get
in touch with him is he was he is
everything good by the way yes he he's
following us you said yes oh I see I see
it all right I think I know what you're
getting that I think I'm picking up what
you're putting down yeah okay all right
perfect
Hey
what's going so the peeps I loved Pete
Wilson let's cut to the chase I have a
friend with no arms or legs he was
kicking legs as a prosthetic right we
think it would be downright [ __ ]
hilarious
to give him crack and watch him sprint
down the street on his chicken legs
that does sound quite humorous it sure
does
now there's a wrench in the plan I
almost got my [ __ ] car towed
well I was waiting for you and I had to
pay the [ __ ] tow truck driver so I
only got 120 bucks oh yeah that's a damn
shame
Thanks you know that's that is a damn
shame and I'm sorry you had to deal with
that so I think I thinkwell 120 wait how
much were you gonna charge for it in the
first place I was gonna charge 250 okay
well since that was our fault I'll pay
this lovely gentleman what was your name
by the way now thank Melbourne okay I'll
pay you 125 dollars just to offset that
fee that way you can pay my friend Jimmy
here the full price and everyone's happy
oh no no it's only 120 now so if you pay
him that and then he pays me 120 I think
that settles yeah okay yeah I'll give
him 120 and then everything will be
settled okay all right then if you
should have just received good payment
then my friend Jimmy here anymore just
to make sure everything goes according
to plan okay I can actually cover that
okay perfect Lanie yeah go for it okay
there you go and there for everything
and make sure everything's great don't
know it's just you you give me the crack
yes sure I'll put it in your you think
you could just pick it off the ground or
should I put in your trunk that's a good
idea I'll watch from here to make sure
no anyone here
huh no my backpack is full of water it's
a water back Camelback so I stay
hydrated on the go all right there you
go set this at the very bottom of your
trunk okay
yes all right I think we're all even see
I kind of yeah yeah we're good perfect
just a good way to do business it's
amazing
Wow well thank you mel and thank you
Jimmy for bringing me yeah yeah I'm here
not because I just okay so do crack I
think let's go oh that's good that's a
good one that was a good buddies a
little chest okay all right okay well
you did it that was your first crack
sale yes Wow
what something we uh so hold on I'm
still kind of lost on the math that just
kind of happened
hold on let me I just need I'm gonna
park for a second and meditate on that
okay and really try to think about it or
I'll think to I'll get back to you in a
second okay I'm having so much fun with
this yes
oh my god we are aware that we got
scammed we're aware of it we know that
we know that's what you call a joke that
is the joke okay let me hear you see
this this is what happened oh it's a
joke Wow chat sometimes you worry me
sometimes you really really worry me not
because you're dumb which sometimes you
are most of the time but moreover the
fact that how dumb you think I what did
you get the mental math I was trying to
run the numbers in like I don't know so
I actually did it so basically we gave
for the discount right because yeah I I
gave him the first hundred and twenty
for the tow truck yeah and then I gave
him 120 for the down down yeah and then
and then she know then you gave him then
we gave
crack and then we didn't get any money
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] piece of
poop
he he he scammed us yeah us absolute it
I don't know how that even slip past us
that wouldn't get any money from that in
fact we gave him money and crack oh you
were supposed to get fair but what was
your excuse for giving him $120 well he
started talking about pizza and like I
don't know people start talking about
food it makes no sense when we're trying
to talk about money yeah I don't get it
I don't get it okay he's like some kind
of genius he selects some kind of
mastermind to the police you got a call
what was that officer's name I didn't
even catch his name who's really nice
what I'll do is I'll tweet out I'll
tweet out vet we were supposed to sell
crack to this guy Mel and he totally
robbed us kind of double-crossed us
double-crossed us holy double you think
I should just call nine one directly
about it call nine one directly about it
I will but maybe don't mention that we
were trying to sell it cuz we never
actually sold it yeah you're true we
can't recharge we never sold it exactly
just gave it away
right for paying in yeah we lost money
yeah how do I write that in a in a
message I'll fit I'll figure it out
don't worry about it
oh god my thigh oh I gotta go Hospital I
think those car crashes are finally
catching up to us
Oh God well you better go me yeah
okay I reported it to the police they
should respond immediately
no no no I said we the Royal we wait
there he is
state he's four thirty in the car I have
to bunion but he's right parents just
keep an eye on he's all right you
weren't did you see that
look I've got my I've got my eyes on you
yeah you just wait oh you put put this
down
oh it's you oh that bite your finger off
for this oh this you want me to put this
down huh yeah I wish you would
oh I wish you would know yeah you won't
door no way no balls no balls you won't
do it guts yeah you know you don't know
I bet you're so experienced in it but
you're too intimidated by the girth of
my finger oh oh oh I'll never seen
someone do that before you're hardcore
wait who me yeah we've all said me I
haven't I have no idea which one you
wouldn't blow in the blow yeah I was I
was talking to Brenda what are you what
do you think about her well I mean I
think she's mean I just said hi to her
no no shut shut shut your face your face
hold she's beautiful and lovely and and
sweet Oh Oh Jimmy he's right here I've
been doing deranged
excuse kicks key excuse you excuse you
hey sorry I'm so sorry
well I'm special too and I feel like you
that doesn't make you allowed to say how
friends settle our differences Oh
bye-bye
dance rock dance novel that is that is
fair I'd um well actually it's not fair
but I accept
car alright fine yeah I was gonna say
that's pretty good hey that's really
good right I just got to remember back
to choreography school of how the right
moves which feet go in front of which
arm
just you wait once I remember though
you're what you got you got I'm still
thinking about it just it's been a while
I just got up here I didn't I didn't
want you to see that what are you doing
well I just we were we just sold crack
but we didn't sell crack because Mel
stole from us and then no no no we
didn't sell crack it was Jimmy's crack
this this man here crack said that you
were mean and I I I guess I was in a
dance battle for your honor huh okay
Stan punch her in the face well I mean
she punched me in the face - so I guess
that's just how she shows you know
affection face like out of aggression or
yeah are you saying someone paid me to
someone who did it all right how much
how much he paid me $500 I paid you 500
Walt home all right so if I pay you $500
you'll tell me who who paid you to punch
her in the face yes oh all right okay I
see how this is but you better tell you
better tell I'll deal with you how much
how much money do I owe you for the
dance battle for billion for
hold on I'm in debt to a lot of old
money
Oh what's the down payment I could give
you that would settle that debt I'll
I'll lower it you couldn't give me like
five dollars all right okay that that's
fair I'll I'll give the rest and when I
when I can that's good I'll give a cool
guy discount
that's like 99 percent there you go all
right what Mel Mel mag Mel wait he's
over there Mel Mel tell me the name tell
me an email tell me your name relax
relax relax his name
uh-huh boys kale so de kale Soze all
right and where could I find a mr. Soze
I think he just ran into the hospital
what what did he look like
blond guy he's right there in the
hospital Hospital seconds okay whoa okay
all right oh my god please no running in
the hospital lobby sorry Hey okay mr.
kale I don't see anyone blond with a
moustache hmm yeah what what cop oh that
cop he's blond with a moustache oh wait
why would a cop pay Mel $500 to punch
Brenda in the face wait wait are you you
saying that I'm saying that maybe he's
trying to try to get you to maybe try to
confess about the whole crack thing
right in front of an officer that son of
a [ __ ] where is he
oh no running no running no running get
after him come on wait after him full
speed walking
we're not running yeah yeah yeah other
approach haha we've got you all
justified no you're gonna give me a
goddamn name you're gonna give me a
goddamn man crying okay all right I'm
sorry I got you all right all right
there you go I'm sorry I'm sorry about
that that should cover the medical bills
now how about you just tell me who paid
you in the face he was the guy that was
harassing her earlier yeah Wow that
makes complete and utter sense thank you
all right I guess this makes us even
then okay well not entirely well I mean
what why not
oh my god oh my god oh Jesus great he
runs like he's on crack oh oh I see the
irony go god that's funny that's funny I
just make that that kind of joke but I
need I need I need medical any medical
there's a hospital
Terry is gone avenge me avenge me okay
there he goes there's your chance three
another car yeah
alright I'll make my way hey wait a
minute
did my friend avenge me what because I
was busy gloating at you I need you to
pay to fix to my [ __ ] hood how is that
my fault
toward you fifty duck that's not an
explanation of fault but alright fine
alright there you go I'm sorry about
your hood but I'm gonna work I guess
this makes us even
absolutely absolutely I'm sorry I
thought that you and I hit the girl you
liked and I told you a fake name and
then I told you another fake name when I
hit you with brass knuckles
we did another fake name so al Jabar was
no he paid me he paid you how much how
much did you pay him
I mean a bunch of bread and dough in the
face no Stan
Jimmy Stan he is a liar I did not do
this Jimmy what is he like the wine no I
have not Jimmy you tried to sell me to
crack the first moment that you met
you've tried you've changed yeah it's
changed how do you know changed you've
changed you've changed can't believe you
Jimmy Jimmy just don't talk to me I'm an
incredible pain I have to get to the
hospital
but we're even Mel we're even okay I'm
not done with you guys stop crawling
like this like this my spine is very
painful I'm gonna just pick you up I'm
gonna pick you up okay
you wouldn't know balls water precious
Oh God
Oh I got a response back from 9-1-1 I'm
just gonna pick you up while you respond
to that okay all right they were just
wondering if the the thing was an
illegally acquired item I told them that
you got it legally I mean I didn't tell
them it was crack I just I assumed you
got it legally what the item was in
question you're asking what the item was
was a collectible bobblehead
okay telling the manga I got a mope a
bit longer I gotta wait for Brenda
Brenda we'll check me in no there's
gotta be a doctor we gotta listen to
procedure no don't run hello just step
over my body under the way wherever
you're going oh thank you yeah Brenda's
not here so you should probably just get
up and oh okay yeah you're right there I
guess I feel okay all right [ __ ] I need
water
all right I feel better and also the
police are gonna find Mel and they're
gonna give them a stern talking-to about
manners so I think we're good there yeah
okay how about that burger and then
nothing
we'll call it from there yeah buddy
burgers
friend burgers pal burgers and then
we'll sell more drugs or not allegedly
allegedly no I mean it's not an
allegation I mean we sell drugs it's
what we do we do not we do not say that
in public with other people list yeah
it's probably smart of you take that in
front of the hospital what are you
talking about yeah no it's it's fine
they're legal I think we work at a
pharmacy
yeah it's just oxys perfectly legal it's
perfect okay sure make sure that cue
sometimes looks like an oh we got that
first three digits the cue looks like a
no it's a cue all right how about that
Burger buddy burger buddies buddies
my car's so [ __ ] up I mean I'm short
on money or else I'd help you I don't
know where it all went
no don't don't worry that you've spent
enough money today just randomly giving
it to Mel
well not Brandon I get why you kept
giving it to him no I mean believe me I
learned we learned after the yeah we
learned after the deal yeah and you just
kept he just kept asking you for more
money and you just kept giving it to him
buddy but he gave me information I
needed
I need I needed that information it was
fake he was lying
what but he's the first time he quit but
then the car you just got you to just
pay him I need an oxy here your own
pocket I need an oxy give me an oxy oh
god no I need an oxy I put a mine away I
need a toxic what I'm gonna gas up then
we're gonna get some burgers okay your
burgers are better than the oxy they're
they're they're almost like a drug
they're so addicting these burgers are
so good
lot of D lot of daughter what he what it
uh sorry I'm taking
[Music]
you